now talking about the last year you'll
remember how in 2020 lockdown
restrictions were eased at different
speeds in different areas the so-called
tier system
but as more people get vaccinated
attention is starting to turn again
as to how the current set of
restrictions could be loosened an
analysis released today by the labour
party says that infection rates are
coming down
slower in poorer areas and particularly
slowly
in the 20 so-called red wall
constituencies that were lost by the
party in 2019.
well we can talk now to the labor mayor
of greater manchester andy burnham thank
you very much for being on the program
and mr burnham um now you've said
that there's a strong case to send
vaccines to areas
with lower life expectancy so are you
saying then that poorer people
should receive the vaccine before older
people in more affluent areas
it's got to be a judgment based on on
health uh sophie so
what i'm saying is uh the life
expectancy
rate varies very widely across the uk
there are places
where it's 10 years behind the areas
where it's
its highest so basically what that means
is
in those areas people in their 60s have
the same level of health as people in
their 70s
in other areas um and it also is the
case
i have to make this point as well that
those same areas where life expectancy
is lowest
tend to be the places where more people
are out at work in those key professions
so working in essential retail in
supermarkets
or driving buses or uh driving taxis
so clearly they are at uh greater risk
i'm not saying this morning
diverged completely uh from the uh
the the phase set out by ages
um put forward by jcbi but i am saying
put greater supplies of the vaccine into
those areas where life expectancy
is lowest and allow greater flexibility
for people to be called earlier
you said that it's a judgment but isn't
that almost a problem
the more complicated you make the system
the slower it's going to be
the more complicated it's going to be it
isn't speed everything right now and is
it not better just to keep things simple
there's certainly an argument for that
uh sophie keep things simple and it does
help with the rollout and
bear in mind you know it's gone very
well so far and i'm not coming on this
morning to criticize
the government that the minister who i
think is on the program
has done a good job and i've said that
to him what i am saying is in this next
phase though
i think we need to adopt a more
sophisticated approach if
we are going to achieve what we all want
to do which is
to protect more people and save more
lives
it stands to reason that people out
on the front line in a supermarket or on
public transport
who have poorer levels of health are at
greater risk than people who are
at home and not particularly at risk and
in this first phase we've seen
an approach where all areas were given
the same level of vaccine and everyone
moved in step
i think there is a very strong case in
this next phase
for putting greater supplies of vaccine
into those areas
where life expectancy is lowest there's
a real
debate around this isn't there you know
who who should be moved up the list
should be key workers should it be
people with as you say where their life
expectancy is lower
and do you support this idea then that
um key workers
teachers supermarket workers as called
for by kyocera and tony blair should be
moved up
the list no i'm going to stick with what
the jcvi
has said so obviously they've set out
categories nine categories based on
age and i think it is the case that
um the vast majority of of um serious
illness and and sadly death has
occurred in those in those age bands i
think it accounts for 99 or
certainly in the high 90s percent of
cases
but what i am saying though this morning
is i have greater flexibility within
that so particularly teachers or support
staff i would say
have a case to be brought forward
particularly if they're in those areas
where the life expectancy is lowest and
the case rates
are higher that's the approach that i'm
that i'm calling for
i mean there is a case just to take
teachers outside of the
the whole um the whole program and just
vaccinate people working in schools
and there is a case for that and i'm not
saying i necessarily disagree with that
but but broadly let's have an approach
here that sticks to what the jcbi have
said
but focuses more on communities
that have the poorest health and where
people tend to be more out at work
and the vaccine rollout seems to be
going really pretty well
so far and credit to the government for
that and when do you think we should
start thinking about easing
lockdown it needs to be done carefully
um and i think so far the date of early
march
for for schools to return feels about
right
to me what i would say though is let's
not have
a return to the tiers that we had before
we don't believe they worked and
the better approach we think would be a
phased
national release from lockdown where
other sectors can return
after after schools when it's judged
right to do so
that also means keeping in place
obviously the national support uh for
the sectors that will take
take longest uh to return so we we we
don't feel that the tiers were
it was a divisive approach in the end uh
and created a lot of confusion amongst
the public as to the
to the rules that they were being asked
asked to follow and in our region here
in the north
west where uh greater manchester was in
a higher tier than the liverpool city
region
where you know shops opened for longer
and there was bars and restaurants still
open
what happens in those circumstances is
you give people an incentive to travel
from one part of a region
to another and that of course can lead
to spread of the virus and i think the
figures in liverpool suggest that that
is exactly what happened
before christmas so i don't see a case
for a return to the tears
i think the prime minister is talking
about a a national phase release from
lockdown
here in greater manchester we would
certainly support that
um you say that you don't believe the
tier system worked and from
a greater manchester perspective who
seemed to be stuck in the high tiers for
so long i can understand that
but at the same time you know you
mentioned liverpool it does seem to work
in other areas and if you look at
liverpool
they went into tier three in 14th of
october last year
a case rate of 406 468 sorry per 100
000 people but by the end of october
that dropped right back down to 315 so
in some areas the tier system did work
didn't it
people if you look at what actually
happened in that instance people
say that liverpool was already showing a
decrease uh before
before the tier system came in i think
there are big
examples where you can argue it both
both ways possibly
uh sophie but overall we've looked at
the analysis
and certainly in greater manchester the
tier system at no
point uh turned the number of cases
around and and
brought a sharp decline possibly
dampened the number of cases
but we don't think was sufficient to
stop um the spread of the virus and
even in liverpool which was in a t it
wasn't in no tier before christmas
that the tier that it was in didn't of
course stop the to stop the spread
and the key thing to bear in mind here
is the
emergence of the new strains so we've
got a bigger challenge on our hands
than the one we had last year and the
the tears
weren't strong enough to contain the the
old milder
form of the virus they certainly won't
be strong enough to
um to contain these new more aggressive
strains
that we're seeing emerge around the
country so the
the phase national approach uh is the
right one as far as i can see it will
just be clearer be
better understood by everybody and i
think
businesses will know where they stand i
think what we've got to avoid
is the stop-start approach that we saw
last year where businesses are
able to open then all of a sudden
they're being asked to shut again so
they just can't plan
in that kind of situation we need a kind
of you know
a more method methodical approach uh to
this um to this whole thing
and there's a crucial crucial thing
sophia i just need to say that needs to
be in this mix as well
test and trace is now working better
than it was uh we've
been working with the national system
and it's got to a higher standard
what isn't working is support for people
to self-isolate
that is the weak link in the chain it's
our achilles heel at the moment
dido harding said last week that 20 000
people every day being contacted
but then saying they can't afford to
self-isolate
we cannot allow that situation when
there are these
aggressive new strains around we have to
put in place
a simple system that covers people's
wages
uh who otherwise would not be able to
have that support
if they're asked to self-isolate um just
finally with your
health former health secretary hat on
there's been reports around this weekend
that the
government's planning a big shake-up of
the nhs effectively rolling back the
2012 reforms
putting more power back in the hands of
ministers do you think that's the right
thing to do
but it makes me smile because i don't
know if you remember but i vehemently
opposed those at lansley reforms at the
time and said that they would
cause the problems that they have i.e
much
greater evidence of the private sector
in the nhs
and a weakening of ministerial
accountability so um it's a decade on
when actually we really shouldn't have
gone down this way in the in the first
place but
yes i do support it but what i wouldn't
support is a complete centralization of
the nhs
going to a very top-down approach i have
no problem at all with ministers having
more control
but they need to work to give more
devolution to areas like greater
manchester
so that we can work on the ground to
take health out of its silo and link it
to housing
and all of the other things that build
that build people's health if anything
if we've learned anything this year
sophie
we should learn that health is built in
in communities in workplaces
and there are far too many places across
england where people don't
have a home or a workplace that supports
good health
and what we need to do going beyond this
is focus on those health inequalities
and that means taking a place based
approach uh to looking at health a more
devolved approach